Через ці труби, за планами "Газпрому",
до Німеччини додатково надходитиме 55 мільйонів кубометрів російського газу на рік.
Близько 70 працівників на німецькій ділянці "Північного потоку-2"
завершують будівництво проекту, готовність якого оцінюють на 95 відсотків.
Дебати про необхідність газопроводу "Північний потік-2" не вщухають,
але його будівництво вже майже завершується.
Тут, на балтійському узбережжі Німеччини, будівельні роботи вступили у фінальну стадію.
Ось ця інфраструктура з'єднає "Північний потік-2" із європейською газотранспортною системою.
Загальна вартість проекту - 8 мільярдів євро, довжина газогону - 1230 кілометрів,
закладено вже 87 відсотків труб.
По суті, цей проект - брат-близнюк "Північного потоку - 1", запущеного 8 років тому.
"Північний потік - 2" у Європі став предметом запеклих дебатів і критики.
З технічної точки зору, відмінностей немає.
Діаметр труб такий же, такі ж специфікації матеріалів.
Утім, політична ситуація принципово інша,
конфлікт між Росією та Україною суттєво впливає на цілий проект.
Представники проекту кажуть, що під час реалізації "Північного потоку -1"
саме Данія першою видала дозвіл на будівництво.
Тепер же свою згоду на "Північний потік -2" Данія видала останньою.
У Данському енергетичному агентстві довго вирішували, чи відповідає маршрут газогону
екологічним нормам.
Але представники проекту вважають, що тут політика давно переплелася з економікою.
Політично наш проект - об'єкт запеклих дискусій, з одного боку,
через геополітичний аспект,
а з іншого - через чіткі економічні інтереси учасників цієї політичної дискусії.
Україна, Польща, Сполучені Штати та країни Балтії вважають,
що труби "Північного потоку-2" - це політичний проект Кремля,
який може бути використаний для тиску на Європу.
Німеччина ж навпаки, незважаючи на санкції проти Росії,
підтримує "Північний потік-2", і німецькі компанії беруть участь у будівництві газогону.
Але за умови, що транзит російського газу через Україну буде збережено.
Тут, у курортному містечку Любміні на балтійському узбережжі Німеччини
ностальгують за часами, коли газ з Росії не викликав такий спротив.